the sports gods up in the clouds in
another dimension we join them now at
their monthly meeting
and finally on universe point I'm given
Bo a dirty layout Callahan after the
handlers stole nine desperation scoober
it's gonna be sick
all right thanks frisbee oh it's
Ultimate Frisbee the cooperation bro
okay uh anyway we're moving on now to
hockey what do you got for us hockey
right um thank you well it's just about
time for the playoffs and I gotta say if
the Capitals don't start giving a hoot
about their special teams defense then
I'm gonna give him the boot early again
but as for the Minnesota Wild all right
well thank you so much hockey that was
very interesting but moving on to
football what's going on the Champions
League I actually do still ceiling psg
or what okay hold on I'm not finished
talking about hockey hockey cool down or
you're gonna get two minutes no I'm not
going I'm a big sport and yet I get no
respect around here yeah big sport in
Winnipeg hey that's the largest city in
Manitoba you're talking about what's
everybody's beef with hockey anyway just
throw it out there ah you sure this is a
road you wanna go down Hawk you sure AM
I'm sure that a moose loose in a poutine
Factory let's do this
all right uh so they won't well um the
puck is hard to see on TV sometimes so I
mean it is hard to see hockey he's got a
point I mean I hate to say it hockey but
sometimes I feel like it's like your
pucks too tiny it's like a little
charred little burger patty just sitting
around yeah we're like a little
flourless chocolate torte all right so I
get it guys my puck is tiny but I mean
golf's got a smaller ball no one seems
whoa hold on I think my balls are just
fine what do you think mini golf I would
argue that golf balls are too big okay
I'm gonna tell you what your problem is
you're Hawking this is coming from over
20 years sales experience you expand it
in the wrong markets man Florida Tampa
Bay I mean only ice take care about
Center pina coladas you gotta identify
your niche
you got to own your nice bro you got to
know your knees and own URIs look here's
my problem I don't know what icing is
does anyone know what icing is I mean
I'm pretty sure I know what icing is
Oleg are you gonna say something about a
cake my sword if you're gonna say torque
I knew it y'all need to try his little
torte so you won't believe they're
flourless hold on guys I think our
racing was open
I can't pronounce any of your players
names I hate Russians
I hate Putin frankly wouldn't surprise
me if your damn pinko commie spy Wow
okay um well I guess that's a lot to
digest thank you yours a bomb too damn
slow right uh well I guess uh nobody
likes hockey then I like hockey Thank
You field hockey I appreciate stage
being a field okay I'm gonna tell you
all why hockey is great it combines the
best elements of all your sports it's
like a soccer cuz we have goals but you
don't take 20 minutes to ticky-tock up
the field and it's like football because
we have big hits but we don't take a
week off afterwards and it's like boxing
and a UFC because we are fighting but we
don't use gloves we have less teeth and
it's like we use a stick like golf and
the cross and it's all done on ice what
kind of ice are you talking about man
that don't look like what is it
hockey holy holy tell me that's now
yours it is
I probably shouldn't hit in the Stanley
Cup
you said they were flourless
[Music]
you